[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh si un jour tu reviens viens viens toi
Jésus le
morivant c'est sûrement dans notre
maison qu'on te
soignera bien bien bien quand tu
reviendras mes deux garçons seront la
ils te poseront 30000 questions
auxquelles tu répondras venu de loin
très loin tu as mis longtemps long
pourquoi tu par je sais pas est-ce que
tu as faim oui tu as des
enfants beaucoup oui tu sais dessiner je
sais fais-moi un dessin tiens voilà
c'est joli chez toi très joli tu venu
comment à pied tu as une maman oui quel
est son nom Marie qu'est-ce que tu as au
main qu'est-ce que tu as au main
qu'est-ce que tu as au main rien quand
tu reviendras ce sera bien bien bien
quand tu reviendras ce sera bien
ouais quand tu reviendras ce sera bien
bien bien tu seras chez moi tout comme
chez
toi quand tu reviendras pas de si loin
loin loin tu ébattas mes voisins
ouais mais tu n'ébatteras pas mes
garçons à qui te poseront leurs 30000
question tu es venu de loin très loin tu
as mis longtemps longtemps pourquoi tu
B est-ce que tu as faim faim oui tu as
des
enfants beaucoup tu sais dessiner je
crois fais-moi un
dessin tuens voilà c'est joli chez toi
très joli tu es venu comment à pied tu
as une maman
ouais quel est son nom Marie qu'est-ce
que tu as aux main rien qu'est-ce que tu
as aux main rien qu'est-ce que tu as au
main rien quand tu reviendras ce sera
bien bien bien quand tu reviendras ce
sera bien
ouais mais tu n'empêcheras pas mes
garçons à de trop poser leurs 300
questions tu es venu de loin je suis
venu de loin tu as mis longtemps j'ai V
très longtemps pourquoi tu parâles
pourquoi je suis ble est-ce que tu as
faim t our tu as des enfants plein tu
sais dessiner je sais fais-moi un
dessin tiens voilà c'est joli chez toi
très joli tu es venu comment à pied tu
as une maman ouai quel est son nom Marie
qu'est-ce que tu as au main rien
qu'est-ce que tu as au main qu'est-ce
que tu as au main rien qu'est-ce que tu
as
rien
rien rien rien
rien rien
rien
ri
Ren Ren
[Musique]
ren